l'heure du laitier un premier camion a
débuté la noria des livraisons du lait
du coeur un million de litres 40 semi
remorques vont être offertes aux banques
alimentaires depuis la laiterie de saint
denis de l'hôtel
c'est une très grande fierté dans le
contexte actuel qu'on est en train de
vivre la contexte quand même extrêmement
difficile pour les gens difficile pour
les agriculteurs difficile pour les
collaborateurs et donc voir
qu'aujourd'hui tout cet élan de
solidarité cette fierté qui s'est vu il
s'est développé c'est c'est très
important toute la filière lait de la
région centre val de loire s'est engagé
dans ce don au moment où les
associations des deux plus démunis
étaient en rupture de stock
nous sommes dans une situation très
critique en ce moment dit elle à la
crise sanitaire nous avons de plus en
plus de demandes chez les étudiants chez
les ddd des personnes du secteur de la
restauration qui n'ont plus de travail
en inde où on a besoin de plus en plus
de denrées alimentaires dont le lait qui
est vraiment une denrée principal pour
l'alimenter soeur au quotidien
l'opération était monté en urgence et
entre dans le cadre de la responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises laitières
c'est une grande satisfaction d'avoir
participé à cette opération un million
de litres on sait que c'est c'est
vraiment énorme comme volume
moi je suis souvent sollicités par les
associations qui sont 220 pour du lait
notamment donc là de pouvoir répondre à
cette hauteur c'est vrai qu'on sait
qu'on va aider quasiment autant de
familles derrière et c'est vraiment un
bonheur de pouvoir participer à cette
cause à une période où le lait s'exporte
difficilement cette énorme dont offre un
débouché aux producteurs une déduction
fiscale et surtout une précieuse denrée
alimentaire aux familles démunies
tout le monde est gagnant